it's been over two weeks since i spent a
ton of money on air tags and accessories
and in this review i will be sharing my
honest thoughts and new findings about
ear tags
and in what ways they work better than i
expected along with the three main
issues that i have with them
and also depending on your use case who
would be better served by buying tile
and yes some of you should i'll be
skipping talking about specs since you
guys already know that
as well as accessories since angelica
did a great job
on her video on the best air tag
accessories and which third party ones
you should buy and which ones to avoid
so you guys can check out the video
after this one with that if you enjoy
our videos consider subscribing to help
us reach our goal
of 1 million subscribers by the end of
the year we would really appreciate it
now one of my favorite things about air
attacks is just how simple they are to
use
and set up unlike competitors you don't
need to download apps or even register
and you don't have to wait for software
updates or even hit a button
you just pull the tab and place it close
to your phone and the connect screen
just pops up
and a few seconds later you just choose
what you want to label it and you're
done
my parents or even my grandmother could
set these up and use them without any
issues
so they would make absolutely great
gifts for people to have iphones
in fact i've already gifted a set now
that leads me to the other biggest
advantage of air tags
which is the network and i want to
address a major misconception
the find my app is installed on all
iphones and it runs automatically when
needed
while being secure and not using much
data and to use air tags you do need to
have
ios 14.5 or newer installed but
a lot of people think that only those
with ios 14.5
can help find other air tags the truth
is that
anybody with an iphone running ios 14 or
even 13
can help find your lost ear tag and what
is shocking
is that 98 of active iphones have these
versions installed
so practically everyone can help track
your air tag and that doesn't even
include
macs and ipads the other misconception
is the sound that an air tag will make
if it is disconnected from your iphone
and there is no iphone nearby
some people were worried that their gear
would start making sounds after a while
if for example they left on vacation but
no worries
thanks to the accelerometer if your item
isn't moved while you're disconnected it
will not randomly start going off
but i'll touch on this more in just a
bit one thing that i've discovered in my
testing
is that when you put your air tag into
lost mode and you're out of range
it doesn't just constantly put out a
signal to be found
apple doesn't tell us how often it pings
but after a few tests in popular spots
my ear attacks kept being found
just after 15 minutes of being
disconnected and being in that loss mode
and that does sound about right since
that's exactly how often tile sends out
a signal
now i thought that it would be found
right away if there's somebody with an
iphone nearby but it wasn't which was
annoying at first but now i know that
it's a good thing because if it did ping
all the time
the battery life would be nowhere near
the one year of rated battery life
but possibly only just a few weeks if it
just had to keep sending out that signal
another thing that i didn't know before
is that after setting up your air tag
that network of apple devices will ping
off of it when it is away from you
and it will update location of your item
without you even having to put it into
lost mode
the way apple set it up if you're ever
away from your tag it will update its
location
in the app without sending you
notifications so if you lose an item
somewhere around people
there's a good chance that once you
realize that you've actually lost it
you will have a location listed so you
can go and find it right away
and now let's get into the first problem
that i've experienced with the air tag
which is actually making me wish for a
better pro version of the air tag
and that is how accurate the location
shows and even more so
the range in my testing i had multiple
times where the find my app shows
location
but it is a fair bit off from where the
tag actually
is now i'm not sure if that's because a
moving car picked it up
and by the time their location was
pulled and sent to apple servers
they have moved already but it
definitely is frustrating
you guys may have seen me wandering
around in my hands on video looking for
my tag
but that's basically what you have to do
since the amazing guiding system
doesn't work until you're realistically
about 30 feet away
depending on if there are obstructions
and that leads me into the second
issue with the air tags that is the
range of air tags and it's definitely
shorter than the tile pro
or samsung's smart tag if you're in line
of sight
those have about 50 percent more range
but indoors with
obstructions they can have up to double
the range of the air tag
and not only that their speakers are
also a lot louder than the ear tags
that uses a special speaker that
actually moves the side of the body
which is why it's quieter but with that
i have to mention that the benefit is
that the air tag is waterproof
so if your keys or anything else gets
dunked it will still work
unlike the others and with two out of
the three issues covered i have to
praise
how well that network works compared to
its biggest competitor
in my first test at the mall where i
placed them right at the entrance
my air tag was found after 15 minutes
while tile took
45 minutes to be found and that is in a
really busy popular place
the second time i placed both in a
parking lot that isn't too busy
and the air tag was found after 30
minutes whereas the tile took two and a
half hours
and then for my final test i hit both of
them next to a trail
that isn't often used my air tag was
found a little bit after
two hours but guess how long it took the
tile to be found
go ahead and pause this video and
comment down below take a guess
because it was in fact found but i want
to hear you guys guesses
all right it took 32 hours to be found
no joke and i was honestly thinking that
it's not going to get found at all
this is why there's no way that i'm
using tile or anything else if i drop
something when i'm hiking or somewhere
that isn't very busy
or maybe i have something stolen i
actually have a very good chance of
finding it with the air tag
and that is what matters most now if you
don't need that awesome visual and
haptic guidance to find your air tag
and you'd prefer a much stronger
connection and a louder speaker
and you live in a busy part of a big
city the tile might work better for you
and probably the biggest reason to buy
it would be paying for its subscription
and getting those smart notifications if
you love something behind
and also being able to share them with
others which is my third problem
or issue with the air tags apple knows
when you've disconnected from an air tag
and you could see your friends and
family with the find my app
so why not add those features that would
make air tags much more useful
and the last thing i want to mention is
something that i'm still not quite sure
how i should feel about and that is the
privacy
features now some people want more
privacy protection from apple but the
same time
tile has none of these and anybody could
slip a tile into somebody's backpack or
say a car and track them
but apple did put in some smart features
to help against this
which at the same time could potentially
tell a thief that they are being tracked
i gave
one of these to a friend and he kept it
with him for two days
but for some reason he never got a
pop-up on his iphone 12
that is running iphone 14.5 even though
he went home
and then he went to a couple other
places that he often visits now i know
some people have gotten a pop-up after
just a few hours so it is just really
weird
how apple is being very private about
this they gave us a little bit of info
but in reality i guess the one thing
that i would appreciate is for apple to
give us
just a very clear explanation about how
these privacy features work
and with that i would love if apple gave
us some options with these
for example i would absolutely love to
change how often it pings
from roughly every 15 minutes to say
about five i would gladly
you know sacrifice some battery life and
maybe have to change it out every three
or four months
to get faster and more accurate tracking
but of course
giving users more customization and
control
isn't really the apple thing to do but
with that said
overall i am really happy with the air
tags the visual and haptic guidance is
awesome when you're trying to find items
at home or in the office
and if you lose something the chance of
you finding it is much greater than with
other options
because of this even if you don't often
lose your items i would highly recommend
buying a couple of these
because even though they aren't gps
trackers or an insurance policy
they are by far the cheapest option to
track things that might be lost or
stolen
and although the air tags could be a lot
better say if the speaker is louder or
if i had better range
and especially if it actually had a hole
in it from the factory so you don't have
to buy all those accessories
i think apple still knocked it out of
the park this is a device that is not
very expensive
and it definitely does the job so thank
you guys for watching let me know your
thoughts down in the comment section
below i have links in the description
and also to
the video that angelica made with the
best third-party accessories so you guys
can save some money
click that circle above if you guys want
to subscribe and help us reach our goal
of 1 million subscribers that would be
awesome
and check out the two air tag videos
right over there this has been max and
i'll see you
in the next video